رغم انضمامه الى احد اهم الانديه في
اوروبا وجد ميسي صعوبه في الاندماج ضمن
فريق الناشئين بسبب قانون كره القدم
الاسباني لم يكن قادرا على لعب اي مباريات
سوى الوديه ومباريات الدوري الكتلوني بسبب
ذلك كانت علاقته مع زملائه في الفريق شبه
معدومه بينما بعضهم نعتوه بالصامت علاوه
على ذلك عادت امه الى روزاريو مع شقيقيه
واخته الصغيره تاركه اياه مع والده فقط
الامر الذي سبب له الشعور بالطوق الدائم
للوطن في نهايه المطاف عام 2002 ادرج ميسي
في لوائح الاتحاد الاسباني الملكي لكره
القدم اي انه صار مؤهلا للعب في جميع
المنافسات كما انه صاحب بعض زملائه في
فريق الشباب بمن فيهم سيسك فابريغاس
وجيرارد بيكيه وبعد ان صار مؤهلا للعب في
جميع المنافسات عرض ميسي موهبته الحقيقيه
لجميع كوادر نادي برشلونه في ذلك العام
اصبح ميسي عضوا في فريق برشلونه الناشئين
والذي عرف باسم فريق الاحلام للصغار اعظم
فريق ناشئين لدى برشلونه خلال موسمه الاول
عام
2002-3 ام سامي بتسجيله 36 هدفا في ثلاثين
مباراه فحسب بسبب ذلك الموسم الاستثنائي
لنجم الصف الاول للناشئين اشتهر في اوروبا
عام 2003 تلقى عرضا من نادي الارسنال
للانضمام الى فريقه لكن رغم العرض المذهل
قرر ميسي الحفاظ على ولائه لبرشلونه كان
موسم 2003
اسطوريا لميسي خلال ذلك الموسم حطم
الارقام القياسيه وشارك مع خمسه فرق في
موسم واحد اذ لعب مع فريق الناشئين الثاني
والناشئين الاول وبرشلونه الثالث وبرشلونه
الثاني بسبب هذا الارتقاء السريع في
الترتيب بدا لاعبون من فريق برشلونه الاول
يميزونه خلال جلسات التدريب واصروا على
منحه فرصه في الفريق الاول
قبل وصوله حتى الى فريق برشلونه الاول كان
جميع اعضاء الفريق الاول يعرفونه في احدى
المناسبات كان كثيرون منهم في استراحه
اللاعبين الدوليين واحتاجوا الى لاعبين
للمشاركه في تدريبات الفريق الاول وكان
ميسي واحدا منهم
برشلونه الدولي الفرنسي الذي شارك في جلسه
التدريب يروي قصه عن ذلك الطفل الصغير
الذي كان يحطم الجميع تماما وشعر بالغون
بالاحراج امام هذا الفتى البالغ من العمر
15 او 16 سنه في ملعب التمرين ولم يستطع
فرانك ريكارد تجاهله وسرعان ما قال فريق
برشلونه الاول انه يجب ضم ذلك الفتى الى
صفوفه
وفي تلك الفتره كان رونالدينيو نجمه
برشلونه وقد راى ميسي يتمرن واختاره ليكون
رونالدينيو التالي اي النجم المقبله
لبرشلونه وكان مصرا ان يصبح ليونيل ميسي
لاعبا في الفريق الاول للنادي مع ان ميسي
لم يلعب رسميا ضمن الفريق الاول في ذلك
الموسم فقد انهى تلك الفتره بتسجيله
اهدافا لاربعه من فرقه الخمسه بمجموع بلغ
36 هدفا في جميع المسابقات الرسميه
بالوصول الى موسم 2004 2005
ظهر ميسي اخيرا مع فريق برشلونه الاول
للمره الاولى بنزوله الى الملعب في
الدقيقه الثانيه والثمانين في سن السابعه
عشره وثلاثه شهور اضحى ميسي اصغر لاعب
يلعب ضمن فريق برشلونه الاول فقد دخل
بديلا في مباراه ضد اسبانيول وجاء هدفه
الاول بعد ذلك مباشره فاصبح اصغر لاعب
يسجل هدفا لفريق برشلونه الاول في مواجهه
نادي الباسيتي في ختام ذلك الموسم والذي
انتهى عام 2005